did you know that the U.S is the only
country in the world that sentences
young people under the age of 18 to life
in prison without any chance of getting
out in 2020 according to one survey more
than 1400 inmates across the country
were sentenced as juveniles to life
without parole
our national correspondent jerika Duncan
spoke with a top prosecutor in Maryland
who launched a program that is focused
on offering Second Chances
dressing up for work in a suit and
walking freely down the halls of this
prosecutor's office is something 49 year
old Arthur miles never dreamed of how
old were you 16 16 years old and you
were given life life plus 20 plus 20
years
in 1990 a jury convicted miles of murder
prosecutors say he and a friend lured 25
year old Pizza Delivery Man Carl krogman
to an abandoned house miles shot him
once but always maintained the gun fired
accidentally prior to that incident he
had no criminal record do you have
remorse absolutely absolutely you know
back at that time not even having like
not even having the mind frame to
understand
the impact of what I did
I was more so in shock for the family of
the victim who take issue with you
getting the second chance what do you
say to them they have a right to feel
however they want to feel in the last 15
years Supreme Court rulings have
accepted research on adolescent brain
development noting differences in
maturity and accountability compared to
adults who commit serious crimes those
rulings have led to bans in some states
on life sentences without the
possibility of parole for juveniles last
year Maryland became the 25th state in
the country to ban juvenile life
sentences without parole state attorney
for Prince George's County Maryland
Aisha Brave boy there seems to be an
attitude for many that you have to be
tough on crime we are absolutely tough
on crime we can both be tough on crime
hold people accountable and be a part of
restoring them so that when they come
back to our communities they are coming
back better than when they left 95
percent of the people who are convicted
of an offense will come home that
includes our young people in 2018 Brave
boy launched the state's first unit to
review the sentences of people convicted
to life as juveniles it's what allowed
Arthur miles a chance at Freedom
December the 18th 2019.
and I was released to my family a week
before Christmas yes
I've been smiling ever since according
to Brave boy's office in the last four
years 40 inmates have been released
under the sentencing review unit and to
date none of them have returned back to
prison so while we get those convictions
and we hold people accountable we also
have to make sure that people have an
opportunity to be restored what did it
mean to you to have that second chance
oh man a second
a second chance
is everything
it's everything and chances may have
been what separated miles from Brave boy
we took a trip to her old high school
the same one Arthur miles attended
around the same time as Brave boy what
was so different that you became the
state's attorney and he ends up
serving a life sentence
you know
when I went to high school the
expectations were high for me I was
going to achieve there was a plan and a
path for me
so many young people at the same time
didn't necessarily have the
opportunities I had as for Miles he's
making the most of what he has now on
the weekends he cuts hair at this
barbershop it's a new life but this one
is filled with possibility are you still
in shock
um life in general
life in general I do wake up every
morning and I smile I always did have a
high Spirit but my spirit is just it's
in the clouds and now it was a
transition when I left I was a child so
now I'm learning the world
well we made multiple attempts to reach
the relatives of the victim Carl krogman
for comment and we're unsuccessful now
krogman's stepbrother said in a local
news interview earlier this year that he
believes in Rehabilitation but he
doesn't think miles should be allowed to
work in the State's Attorney's Office
calling the decision quote disgusting it
is also important to note though that
anyone released through the sentencing
review program goes through a re-entry
process which includes counseling with
needed peer groups and additional
support when it comes to finding a job
and a place to live um yeah you know
this state's attorney Aisha Brave boy
really looking at the criminal justice
system as a whole there's a number of
other things that she's done too but
this one has really been something worth
mentioning I know I keep thinking about
the victim's family though I believe in
second chances and Rehabilitation I
think if you're the victim's family
that's still very hard you said he was
16 had no criminal record no criminal
record and comes from a family that's
father was a police officer oh a police
family even it's an important
conversation to have yes it is yes and
actually said 95 of people come home
thank you Merry Christmas thank you
David thank you everybody